hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the terms
particularly central to interpretation
of the pre-socratic philosopher
Heraclitus is that of logos and this is
a what we could call an ambiguous or
poly semeth term in in Greek it has a
wide range of meaning
I'm not saying necessarily we need to
read all of these potential meanings
into here cleitus --is use of logos but
we should keep in mind that it doesn't
signify just one thing rather the
meanings of the term are connected with
each other and it is quite true as we're
going to see that that Heraclitus makes
the logos you could say with a capital T
in capital L central to his his
metaphysics and even his what we can
call epistemology his inquiry into how
it is that human beings come to know
things or have wisdom or have a correct
account of anything but he also uses the
word in a few other senses so that's
where I want to begin before jumping
into the first passage that's really
central to the overall metaphysical
consent
logos which is fragment one I think it's
useful to work our way into the Herrick
Lydian logos by contrasting it to two
other uses of logos in the fragments and
what we're going to talk about here is
going to stick to those fragments in
which the term logos or you know cognate
of it actually appear we're not going to
try to read it into all sorts of other
fragments as well although that that
certainly is possible to do and I
suppose we should keep in mind that we
are working with fragments coming down
to us largely from philosophers who are
distant from Heraclitus in time and
we're piecing them together into an
account so there is some interpretation
involved here
so in fragment 1:18 in the deals
accounting of the fragments he tells us
that of the accounts low goose he's
using there that's the plural for logos
that he has heard or or listened to none
lead one to to know something
particularly important so what he's
saying here just to begin with is that
there are other logo other accounts
other ways of explaining things out
there already and he has heard some of
them but none of them do what's really
important and what is that he says that
they don't communicate to us or they
don't allow us to know literally gig no
skein that in principle or you know in
terms of wisdom right the the wise is
different from everything else so the
wise here is cellphone which could be
the wise person or it could be
wisdom itself right something that's in
a you could say a privileged position as
far as understanding what's really going
on and this this weren't differing okay
that's an interesting way to translate
it's not a terrible way but it could
also be said to be distanced from
everything else the Greek word is que
hora cement men on being taken to a
distance distancing itself from
everything else meaning that there are
the ways in which everybody else
understands the world and then there's
the way in which the person who has
genuine knowledge understands the world
and the logo that are being given of how
the world works and what might these
logo I be well we know at other places
Heraclitus criticizes for example poets
like homer and hesiod so maybe what we
have here are mythological accounts or
perhaps it's other pre-socratic
philosophers so we don't actually know
or it's it's other thinkers right he's
saying that these accounts are deficient
and so logos at least in this passage is
is not something true it's something
false it gets things wrong it doesn't
lead us into understanding the way
things truly are keep that in your back
pocket for a moment there's another
passage where he talks about soul and
there are there are quite a few passages
where Heraclitus discusses soul and sook
a soul the word we get psychology from
by the way is something distinctively
human right it's a way in which we
beings that are connected with the logos
in some way grasp the world here he's
not so interested in the overall arching
logos here he's talking about a logos
that is you might say particular eyes to
the living bee
and he discusses this in in fragment 115
so here's what he says about that it's a
very short passage here's a translation
of it
yeah so so soul is something that is got
its own process of growth within it
right suitcase st logo so there's the
logos term hey out own out sewn out sewn
is coming Alex ASIS is a noun for that
growth development right and the
suitcase here is is a possessive the the
there is a logos a principal an account
an account that we could understand a
principal driving it a sort of
rationality to it there is a a logos for
the soul or of the soul of its own
process of growth so what goes on within
the living being is subject to a logos
not I won't say a law but a sort of
rationality something that we can
uncover and talk about now I mentioned
that the sort of most important passage
what we might call the Royal Road into
the notion of logos is fragment one so
we should take a look at that very
closely it's a longer fragment than most
of the other fragments that we have and
here's a translation of it but of this
principle logos which holds forever
people prove ignorant not only before
they hear it but once they have heard it
for although everything happens in
accordance with this principle they the
people resemble those with no
familiarity with it even after they have
become familiar with the kind of
accounts and events I discuss as I
distinguish each thing according to its
nature and explain its constant
Dushan but the general run of people are
as unaware of their actions while awake
as they are what they do while asleep so
what does Heraclitus telling us in this
very rich and suggestive passage well he
wrote a book called on nature that we
you know according to legend about this
perhaps you know reliably he dedicated
to the Temple of Diana and you know
presumably it was quite a long and
interesting and cohesive coherent work
in which he was providing accounts about
how things work in the world and he was
presumably not just writing a book
saying hey whoever wants to read it go
ahead and read it
he was presumably going around and
talking to people about this as well so
what he discovers what he sets down here
is that people don't actually grasp what
he's talking about then what is he
talking about he is talking about the
logos the logos is a discourse and
here's where we have sorted you might
say two sides of it so on the one hand
the logos is what is said legacy right
what would the thing in Greek that
actually undergoes the the talking the
giving in account right so we have what
we might call a verbal representation or
verbal account of things but that's
supposed to be of what actually is the
case which is also the logos the
underlying rationality or structure that
is being brought into language and being
depicted so he's saying that everything
happens in accordance kata tone loge own
with everything happens in accordance
with this logos everything is his
they'll say in other places governed or
structured or determined by it and yet
people don't get it they are satisfied
with more
official and fragmentary explanations of
the universe or nature how things
actually work including of their own
place in it and of themselves so this is
kind of an interesting place to begin
what it's suggesting to us is that there
is out there actually we can't even say
out there because we're in there we're
part of it there is just the totality of
the the world or the universe or nature
and it is governed all the way down to
the bottom by this logos which we human
beings can provide a logos on our own
part of which could be correct or
incorrect could connect up with the
logos or could go astray from it now
another thing that he tells us in
passage fragment 2 is that logos is
common what do we mean by common well
let's take a look at the passage itself
he says one ought to follow what is
common although the principle logos is
common the majority of people live as
though they had private understandings
so common here is actually translating
too closely related but at least in this
passage different terms sue knows kai
Kai is and coin owes coin tous is a much
more common term in later ancient Greek
you know Koinonia is is sharing in
something or community in something and
so what is coin tous is what is shared
or participated in by some group or
community or it could be all sorts of
other things we get the word coin name
which describes the later Greek of say
epictetus and the New Testament from you
know this this term coin house Greek
became a common language a shared
language right
suno's is an is a term that is more used
in in Heraclitus and other ancient
authors and it has a similar connotation
of belonging to a group so if we talk
about having a common meal together that
could be a zoo known right that could be
something that is is shared in that way
and so the logos is shared or common in
that respect it pervades everything
there is no escape from it it's it's
everywhere and in everything and at the
same time human beings don't realize
that and that's part of how they get so
mixed up we're gonna come back to that
in just a moment in another passage he
talks about listening not to Heraclitus
but rather to listening to the logos and
if we do that then we will realize that
all is actually one now does that mean
that that Heraclitus himself was a sort
of you know what we nowadays call it
pantheists not necessarily it could be
that what he's trying to convey there is
that everything is part of one gigantic
dynamic system which we could have some
account of it's got its own logos that
we can you know engage in in depiction
or understanding of right in another
passage which actually comes to us from
Marcus Aurelius very interestingly who
thought that Heraclitus was was quite
onto something Marcus Aurelius is
probably one of the stoic authors who we
have who brings up here at cleitus the
most and and probably seem to been
affected quite a bit by by Heraclitus
and probably had access to more of
Heraclitus doctrines and then we do
there's a very interesting passage where
he says that this is what Heraclitus
said humans are involved with the logos
and the word there is home use right
which could mean
having intimate conversation
it can also it has a connotation
sometimes I'm actually being opposed to
but you you're opposed to because you
are actually connected with in this case
I don't think it's it's meaning opposed
to another translation as humans are
intimate with the logos and that logos
governs all it is over everything but
they are distanced from it and the the
Greek term there
tutto DF at our own time yet Ferran is
used in other places in Heraclitus and
we could translate it in in a very
cognate difference right it is the word
that we get difference from through
Latin and then into English the federal
tie literally means there's there's this
the sense of carrying or bearing
something away so things are different
from each other like these two books
because they aren't the same there's
things that carry them away from each
other and so we human beings if we want
to use this sort of spatial language are
intimately involved with the logos and
at the same time we distance ourself
from it or it distances itself from us
and our erroneous interpretations of it
as we try to make it into something that
it's not
or we ignore its features and don't
fully understand it so that's an
interesting one and then finally I you
know there is one example at least in
the fragments that we do possess of
Heraclitus probably there was a lot more
in his original book if we had it of a
cosmic process in which Heraclitus talks
about the logos and here's a translation
of it the turning points of fire we
could be a little bit more elaborate
with this this is how fire develops
itself first see thala shot and if see
half is earth and half is what we
translate as lightning or the
thundercloud or something like that is
one of those terms in Greek that people
aren't quite sure how to translate but
it seems to you know mean something like
that so this is discussing how fire
which is this cosmic you know stuff that
everything ultimately is involved with
or is made of develops itself into other
things
according to Heraclitus now here's where
it gets interesting in terms of the
logos he goes on and he says see drains
off and is measured into the same
principle as before it became earth now
measured into the same principle is
literally the word for for measuring
right the verb and then it's a stone out
own logo quite literally in Greek into
the same logos so logos is governing the
cosmic process by which everything is
exchanged for fire and fire becomes
everything else however we want to
understand that the cosmic process of
change development all the other things
that we could include in that are
governed by the logos so if we develop a
true account which is what Heraclitus
thinks that he's done of the logos then
we have something that is you could say
a verbal interpretation of the capital L
logos that everything is involved with
and can't get away from
you